l'ultimatum lancé il ya une semaine par
les chefs autochtones a finalement été
entendue dès 7h30 ce matin ils étaient
une trentaine de chefs réunis avec le
premier ministre du québec philippe
couillard pour tenter de résorber la
crise à val-d'or jours doit également
lancer ici un appel au calme
d'emblée le premier ministre annonce des
mesures pour soutenir les communautés
des mesures qui totalise des
abaissements d'environ six millions de
dollars qui comporte par exemple le
soutier accentuée pour le centre
d'amitié autochtone et projets de
logements il annonce également la
nomination de fannie lafontaine comme
observatrice de l'enquète du spvm sur
des allégations d'agression de la sûreté
du québec
mais c'est dans les journaux ce matin
que les leaders autochtones ont appris
la nouvelle ce qui a suscité un certain
malaise et leur demandent une enquête
indépendante provincial est restée
lettre morte
plusieurs chefs qui sont restés sur leur
appétit par rapport à une enquête
indépendante sur les agissements de la
sûreté du québec et je ferai pas de
litanies si de ce qu'on constate de ce
qu'on reçoit comme indication depuis
quelques jours sur des possibles de
gestes d'intimidation de représailles de
la part de la sûreté du québec
le chef cris matthew coon come affirme
être déçu de la rencontre iam de ce
point de l'enquète national va se
pencher sur les femmes autochtones
portés disparus diddy et non sur celles
qui vivent encore c'est pour ça qu'on
voulait une enquête romain sial
indépendante
en attendant le premier ministre réitère
sa confiance envers la sûreté du québec
et affirme que des mesures sont en place
pour assurer la sécurité des femmes
la sûreté du québec d'elle-même a décidé
de commencer un programme de porc de
caméras pour les policiers lors de leur
intervention et pour les chefs
la situation demeure préoccupante il
semble y avoir effectivement à
l'intérieur de la sûreté du québec une
culture s'exprime différemment lorsqu'il
s'agit de nos peuples
plusieurs en ont fait allusion ce matin
par l'une au chef qui
il ya très certainement d'autres cantons
peut-être un certain profilage racial
quant aux femmes elle vivrait encore
dans la peur et on parle ils craignent
un an les discussions commencées
plusieurs espèrent voir des choses
concrètes se réaliser sur le terrain
assez peu de vigueur guise radio canada
font rien